Ich bin heute der zuständige Ast für Sie und werde das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Was Sie Fragen haben, suggen Sie bitte nicht mich zu unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin Edil Traut Böhm.
Könnten Sie bitte den Vornamen langsam beschreiben?
Wie alt sind Sie Herr Böhm?
Frau Böhm. Ich bin 51 Jahre alt.
Wie viel ist Ihr Geburtstag?
Wie groß sind Sie Frau Böhm?
Ich bin 1,56 Meter.
Wie viel ist Ihr Gewicht?
Ich bin 71 Kilogramm.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin?
Herr Müller. Mein Hausarzt heißt Herr Müller.
Was fühlt Sie heute zu uns Frau Böhm? Welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Herr Doktor. Ich fühle mich sehr schlecht. Seit 45 Minuten habe ich sehr starke Schmerzen.
Und ich habe auch Atemnot.
Mein Enkel hatte heute Morgen einen epileptischen Anfall.
Meine Tochter hat mich angerufen und hat mir eine schlechte Bescheidung gesagt.
Deswegen hatte ich Angst und hatte sehr starke Schmerzen im Brust.
Wo genau tut es Ihnen weh?
Ganz im Brust.
Ganz im Brust? In der Mitte?
In der Mitte. Strahlen Sie diese Schmerzen aus?
Ja. Ich fühle mich mit der linken Schulter und mit der Kiefer.
Das ist sehr stark Herr Doktor. Ich kann nicht gut atmen.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ja, ja. Drücken wie ein Mensch auf dem Brust.
Verstehe Frau Böhm. Jetzt muss ich das erste Gespräch unterbrechen.
Ich werde einen EKG schreiben und ich werde Blut abnehmen.
Und hier gibt es eine Sauerstoffmaske. Bitte geben Sie.
Ist das eine ernste Situation oder warum machen Sie das Herr Doktor?
Es ist zu früh etwas Genaues zu sagen Herr Böhm.
Frau Böhm, Sie haben Brustschmerzen und es ist neu.
Deswegen muss ich einen EKG schreiben und Blut abnehmen.
Okay, okay Herr Doktor.
Und ich werde die Vitalparameter fassen auch.
Jetzt können wir weitermachen. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 10 am stärksten ist?
Ja, früher hatte ich auch Brustschmerzen.
Besonders beim Laufen oder beim Joggen.
Aber das ist sehr stark. Das ist vielleicht nicht wie alte oder frühere Schmerzen.
Das ist wie 9 oder von 10. Ich kann beschreiben.
Können Sie uns zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ich habe auch Übelkeit. Ich habe nicht erbrochen, aber ich habe auch Übelkeit.
Das ist ein komisches Gefühl. Ich habe gedacht, dass ich sterbe.
Bitte machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorge. Wir sind für Sie da und wir tun alles für Sie, Frau Böhm.
Sie haben Atemnot. Wann haben Sie Atemnot?
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Einatmen oder beim Ausatmen?
Ja, beide. Ich kann nicht gut atmen. Mein Herz schläft manchmal gut, manchmal nicht.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Ja, wie Herzrasen habe ich auch gespürt. Oder Herzstolpern kann ich sagen.
Komisches Gefühl im Herz fühle ich mich.
Haben Sie Atemgeräusche bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe keine Atemgeräusche, aber ich kann nicht gut atmen. Ich kann es nicht bekommen.
Sauerstoff ist nicht ausreichend für mich. Das ist wenig.
Haben Sie Allergen oder Unfertigkeiten?
Ja, ich habe Paracetamol-Allergie.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Mit Hautauschlag.
Ich gebe Ihnen in Venösen Zugang ein Schmerzmittel. Es hilft Ihnen, Frau Böhm. Bitte machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen.
Okay Herr Doktor, ich vertraue Ihnen.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente genommen?
Ja, nach dem Schmerzen habe ich Ibuprofen genommen, aber es hat mir nicht geholfen.
In welcher Dosis?
Zuhause gab es vielleicht 400 mg.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie diese Beschwerden hatten. Wann war das?
Vor ungefähr einer Stunde.
Wann war das letzte Schmerzen?
Bevor.
Sie müssen sagen. Ja, ich hatte seit sechs Monaten solche Beschwerden.
Bevor ein Monat hatte ich. Aber es war nicht schlimm.
Ich war beim Laufen und mit Hilfe des Schmerzmittels hat mein Schmerzen weggenommen.
Wie lange hat es gedauert?
Drei Minuten manchmal. Fünf Minuten. Aber das Schmerz geht nicht zurück.
Aber momentan hat das Schmerzen eine Dauer gehabt, oder?
Ja, es hat eine Dauer gehabt. Und es hat verschlimmert, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie Fieber? Oder Schüttelfrost?
Ich habe nicht gegessen, aber ich habe kalt geschwitzt. Mit dem Schmerzen.
Verstehe. Haben Sie Nachtschweiß?
Das ist heute Morgen. Seit heute Morgen meine Beschwerden.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Okay, okay. Ich verstehe. Nachtschweiß habe ich nicht.
Mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, aber ich habe Übelkeit.
Ja, ich habe es mir notiert.
Haben Sie das Bewusstsein verloren?
Nein, nein. Aber ich musste mit dem Schmerzen sitzen.
Ich musste stoppen und sitzen.
Ich habe gewartet, Schmerzen zurückzugehen, aber das geht nicht.
Außer sitzen, gibt es irgendetwas, das Schmerzen besser oder schlimmer macht?
Ja, ich kann das nicht genau sagen.
Aber bevor ich Schmerzen hatte, habe ich gewartet und sitzen und die Schmerzen sind weggegangen.
Aber in diesem Fall hat mir nichts geholfen.
Verstehe.
Haben Sie Schwellungen in irgendwelchen Körperregionen gemerkt bisher?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Hautverfarbungen gemerkt?
Habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise esse ich gerne, aber wenn ich einige Schmerzen hatte, habe ich nach dem besonders fettigen Essen einige Schmerzen verspürt.
Vorher oder dieses Mal?
Vorher, nicht dieses Mal, vorher.
Verstehe. Aber Ihr Appetit war gut?
Ja, normalerweise gut.
Haben Sie in nächster Zeit Ab- oder Suge genommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Schutulgang und Wasserlassen?
Ich habe chronische Verstopfung, Herr Doktor.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit vier Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme oft Obst und Gemüse. Das hilft mir.
Verstehe. Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja, mein Schlaf ist auch nicht gut. Manchmal wache ich auf. Ich lasse Wasser jeden Nacht einmal.
Wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Einmal.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie seit sechs Monaten diese Beschwerden hatten. Waren Sie schon beim Hausarzt oder ein anderer Arzt?
Mit ähnlichen Beschwerden war ich nicht beim Hausarzt.
Das ist zum ersten Mal.
Zum ersten Mal, ja. Und manchmal huste ich. Seit sechs Monaten, manchmal huste ich.
Husten mit Ausruf oder trocken?
Trocken.
Momentan haben Sie husten?
Ja, ein bisschen habe ich auch.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen, Frau Böhm?
Ja, ich spüre Knie Schmerzen, chronische Knie Schmerzen.
Und seit zwei Jahren war ich einmal beim Orthopedien und habe mir gesagt, dass das ein Kniegelenkverschleiß ist.
Seit zwei Jahren?
Ja.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Manchmal nehme ich Ibuprofen und ein Wolteranzalbe.
Wie oft nehmen Sie Ibuprofen und Wolteranzalbe?
Wenn ich Schmerzen habe, das kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Ibuprofen 400 mg, oder?
Ja, ja, 400 mg.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich leide auf Bluthochdruck seit fünf Jahren und meine Blutfettwerte sind auch hoch.
Seit wann?
Seit fünf Jahren.
Blutfettwerte auch seit fünf Jahren.
Und seit zwei Jahren hatte ich Wundrose.
Seit zwei Jahren.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Mein Unterarm wurde rot. Das war Hautentzündung. Mein Hausarzt hat mir gesagt, das war eine Hautentzündung.
Wundrose. Unterarm.
Ja, Unterarm.
Wie wurde es behandelt?
Mit Antibiotika.
Unterarm. Was nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck und erhöhte Blutfettwerte?
Ich nehme Fluvastatin 20 mg einmal täglich und Norvask 10 mg einmal täglich.
Fluvastatin in welcher Dosis?
Fluvastatin 20 mg und Norvask 10 mg täglich.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche gerne. Seit 40 Jahren zwei Schachtel Zigaretten.
35 Jahre ungefähr.
Seit 25 Jahren.
Ja, zwei Schachtel Zigaretten habe ich.
Das ist zu viel Fragen. Das ist sehr schlecht für Ihre Gesundheit. Haben Sie es versucht?
Ich habe vielmals versucht aufzuhören, aber...
Wir haben auch eine Abteilung. Wir können einen Termin vereinbaren für Sie. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, vor zehn Jahren wurde ich wegen Steißbeinfestür operiert.
Steißbeinfestür. Gut.
Hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Ich hatte auch eine Oberarmfraktur wegen Autounfall vor zwei Jahren.
Wurde es operiert?
Ja, operiert.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr selten.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Einmal probieren.
Was trinken Sie?
Wein.
Ein Glas?
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Seit ich erwachsen war.
Bitte nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich aus. Medizinische Gründe fragen wir immer.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich keine Erfahrung.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin verheiratet.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Ehemann zusammen?
Nein, sie haben nur gebrochen.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei Töchter habe ich.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund, aber mein Enkel hatte heute Morgen einen epileptischen Anfall.
Ich habe eine Anfall.
Gibt es eine chronische Erkrankung in Ihrer Familie?
Ich meine Ihre Mutter, Ihr Vater?
Mein Vater ist vor zehn Jahren an Gehirntumor verstorben.
Wie alt war er?
Er war 70.
Hat er noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich erinnere mich nicht.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter leidet an Herzversagen.
Meine Mutter ist schwach und hat immer Schwellung im Bein.
Beide Beine.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, ich habe zwei Schwestern.
Eine Schwester leidet unter Asperger-Syndrom.
Hat die andere Schwester Probleme?
Nein, sie ist gesund.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich habe als Verkäufer gearbeitet.
Bekommen Sie Ihre Perioden regelmäßig?
Nein, ich bin in Menapol.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frauen erst regelmäßig?
Ja, letztes Jahr, zwei Jahre.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, denke ich.
Waren Sie in Lesterzeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein.
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Was habe ich?
Ich habe sehr stark Schmerzen und Angst.
Ich habe schon Blut abgenommen.
Wir sollten die Ergebnisse warten.
Danach können wir mehr überwissen.
Es ist zu früh etwas Genaues zu sagen.
Ok Herr Doktor Filinand.
Ich habe ein Schweißbein in der Hose.
Schweißbein und Pfister.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Das ist ein Plan.
Ok.
Es geht um Frau Edil Trautböhm.
Sie ist eine 51-jährige Patientin.
Sie wurde am 29.07.1974 geboren.
Sie ist 1,56 Meter groß und 71 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie hat sich seit 45 Minuten auf den Grund geteilt.
Sie ist stehender, drückender, zunehmender.
Sie hat sich mit Ausstrahlung in die linke Schulter und Unterkiefer ausgeschmissen.
Also können wir angenach Pektowis sagen.
Als Begleitsymptomen liegen die Spnoe.
Wo ist die Patientin jetzt?
Können Sie es wiederholen?
Sie ist in der Untermonitorenstation.
Also meinen Sie Intensivstation?
Ja.
Vielleicht Kateter Labor?
Ich warte auf Laborergebnisse.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose lautet an Gna Pektowis.
Welche Risikofaktoren hat die Patientin?
Sie hatte heute einen schmerzigen Anfall.
Die Schmerzcharakter ist sehr typisch.
Als Risikofaktoren zahlen arterielle Hypertonie, Hyperlipidemie.
Sie ist trauer.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen stabil angena Pektowis und instabil angena Pektowis?
Unter stabil angena Pektowis versteht man,
dass die Schmerz unter 20 Minuten dauert.
Nach der Nitroglycerinspray lindert die Schmerzen.
Aber bei der unter unstabil angena Pektowis dauern die Schmerzen über mehr als 20 Minuten.
Und Nitroglycerinspray hilft uns nicht.
Oder hilft der Patient oder die Patientin nicht.
Welche Arten von akut Koronasynchrom kennen Sie?
Anstabil angena Pektowis, Estehebung, Estehebung, Esteelewe Myokardinfarktus oder Noneste Myokardinfarktus.
Drei Arten.
Stemi, Entstemi und instabil angena Pektowis.
Was haben Sie im Notfalldienst durchgeführt bei dieser Patientin?
Zuerst würde ich ein EKG schreiben und die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Und würde ich Labouruntersuchungen durchführen um Blutbild, Troponin und CKMB Werte zu bestimmen.
Welche Vitalzeichen überwachen Sie?
Blutdruck, Herzfrequenz und Sauerstoffsätigung.
Das ist sehr wichtig. Welche Labourwerte steigen bei einem Herzinfarkt?
Wenn Estehebung oder Noneste Myomy gibt es, erwarten wir Troponin Werteerhöhung und CKMB auch.
Und warum steigen diese Werte?
Wegen Herzmuskelsteben.
Herzgewerbeschädens.
Herzgewerbeschädens produziert diese Enzyme.
Genau, durch den Infarkt.
Welche Behandlungsoptionen haben Sie bei dieser Patientin?
Wenn es eine Estehebung gibt, sollten wir so schnell wie möglich eine KTT Angiografie durchführen.
Aber bei der NST-MI oder Instabil Angina Pectoris können wir eine konservative Behandlung durchführen.
Aber danach sollten wir auch eine KTT Angiografie durchführen.
Zuerst müssen wir Acetylsalicylic Säure 300 mg verabreichen und vielleicht Clopidogrel verabreichen.
Und Methoprolol sowie Statin sollten wir verabreichen.
Und wenn Ballondilatationen oder Ständen nicht möglich sind?
Wenn mehr Gefäß betroffen oder wenn Ballon oder Ständen nicht möglich sind, sollten wir Gefäßchirurgisches Konzil verlassen, um eine mögliche Operation zu organisieren.
Was für Operation meinen Sie?
Bypass.
Wie wird eine Bypass Operation durchgeführt?
Unter Narkos diese Operation durchgeführt, soll der Chirurg oder Chirurgin ein Ersatzgefäß hochwahrscheinlich im Bein nehmen und die Herz, wie kann ich sagen, ein...
Also welche Venen am meisten werden verwendet?
Ich erinnere mich nicht daran.
Also die habe ich schon gesagt, aus dem Bein?
Aus dem Bein, aber welche Venasaphenamagna.
Genau.
Ok, welche Arterien werden verwendet, wissen Sie?
Ich wusste nicht, aber Arteria mammillaris.
Genau, Arteria mammillaris oder Arteria radialis auch.
Ok, welche Differenzia Diagnose haben Sie bei diesen Patienten?
Lungenembolie.
Als Erster würde ich Lungenembolie sagen.
Um eine Lungenembolie auszuschließen, würde ich Blutgasanalyse durchschüren und Dedimerwerte bestimmen lassen.
Und gegebenenfalls CT mit Kontrastmittel, Thorax CT, veranlasse ich.
Meinen Sie CT-Angiographie, oder?
Ja, CT-Angiographie.
Ok, welche Symptome sprechen gegen eine Lungenembolie bei diesen Patienten?
Bei diesen Patienten Schmerzcharakterisation und Schmerzintensität.
Spricht gegen Lungenembolie.
Bei der Lungenembolie erwarten wir Schmerzen, aber nicht Neu.
Ok, welche Risikofaktoren kennen Sie für eine Lungenembolie?
Die Gerinnungspathologie, zum Beispiel genetische Faktor 5-Leiden-Mutation, auch genetische Veranlagung, arterielle Hypertonie, Diabetes mellitus und erhöhte Hyperkolesteregnämie, sowie Nikotinabussus oder Nikotinkonsum und Alkoholkonsum.
Und natürlich Immobilisation.
Wie zum Beispiel?
Wie zum Beispiel eine lange Reise oder nach der Operation gesucht oder nach einem Unfall.
Ok, sehr gut.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine PTCA durchgeführt würden.
Also gegebenenfalls, ich meine.
Können Sie bitte PTCA, Herzkatheter, ich meine erklären?
Ja, Herr Oberast, der Ast oder der Radiolog oder der Kardiolog, in der Beine oder im Ellenbeuge eine kleine Schicht machen mit einer Holnadel.
Eine Holnadel wird durch eine Phameral- oder Radialarter eingeführt werden.
Durch die Holnadel wird ein KTT eingeführt.
Ich habe diese vergessen, Entschuldigung.
Dann der Radiolog oder der Ast gibt Kontrastmittel und mit Unterstrahlen können wir Herzkranz oder Herzgefäße beurteilen.
Das ist nicht nur eine diagnostische Methode, sondern auch eine therapeutische Methode.
Gleichzeitig können wir einen Ballon oder Stennt durchführen.
Das ist eine schmerzhafte Methode.
Deswegen können wir eine örtliche Betäubung verabreichen.
Und nach der Untersuchung bleibt der Patient in der Intensivstation.
Okay, also würden Sie bei dieser Patientin eine Echokardiografie durchführen?
Ja, bei der Echokardiografie können wir Herzwand und Ejectionfraktion und Herzarbeit, wie Herzpumpen aktivität beurteilen.
Deswegen sollte eine Echokardiografie durchführen.
Aber wenn es einen ST-elevaten Myokartinfarkt gibt, sollten wir nach der Coronärangiografie diese Untersuchung durchführen.
Okay, können Sie uns bitte eine Echokardiografie erklären?
Echokardiografie ist eine besondere Sonographie.
Bei der können wir Herzgefäßwand und Ejectionfraktion beurteilen.
Das Gerät hat einen Schallkopf und einen Monitor.
Wir tragen ein Gel die Haut auf.
Der Schallkopf sendet Schallwelle und aufnimmt die Gewebeantwort.
Wir können im Monitor die Gewebe oder die Organe beurteilen.
Das ist eine schmerzfreie Methode, die die Patientin oder der Patient nicht vorbereiten.
Nach der Untersuchung können die Patienten ihren gewohnten Alltag fortsetzen.
Es dauert nur 5-10 Minuten.
Gut, kennen Sie Mona BH Schema?
Mona, Morphin, Sauerstoff, Nitroglycerin und Aspirin.
BH?
BH, ich erinnere mich nicht daran.
Also die betablocker ist Heparin.
Okay, was empfehlen Sie dieser Patienten nach der Behandlung?
Nach der Behandlung empfehle ich die Patienten Gewichtreduktion, Fett, Alme, Kohl, Salz, Alme, Diät.
Und mit dem Rauchen natürlich aufzuhören.
Und die anderen chronischen Erkrankungen regelmäßig zu kontrollieren.
Arterielle Hypertonie und Hyperlipidemie.
Ja, ich empfehle dieses, Herr Oberast.
Und natürlich, Sie sollten die Medikamente erst nehmen.
Gut, vielen Dank. Sie haben es gut gemacht. Bitte gehen Sie zum Impfotest und nehmen Ihr Zertifikat, meine Kollege.
Insha'Allah, auf jeden Fall. Danke schön.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen. Ich würde gerne Sie Ihnen vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, bitte.
Ich berichte über die 51-jährige Patientin, Frau Edile Traut-Böhm, die 1,56 Meter groß ist und 71 Kilogramm wiegt.
Die Patientenstätte ist heute notwendig bei uns wegen der 45 Minuten Bestehung,
der Progradierung der Brustschmerzen mit dem Unterkiff und linken Schultern ausgetragen.
Begleitende Symptome sind Nausea, Dyspne, Palpitations- und Tachycardi, Kaltschweiß und Todangst.
Zufolge dem Patienten sind die Schmerzen nach einem Schlechtnachricht aufgetreten und sich im Verlauf der Zeit verstärkert.
Dagegen nimmt sie regelmäßig Fluvastatin 20 Milligramm einmal morgens, Norvask 10 Milligramm einmal morgens und Ibuprofen 400 Milligramm Tablet und Volteransalve bei Bedarf.
Vor zwei Jahren hatte sie einen Erythropell und wurde mit Antibiotika behandelt.
Sie wurde wegen Pyloriadenis vor zehn Jahren operiert und vor zwei Jahren wurde sie wegen Humerusfraktua operiert.
Sie hat Paracetamol-Allergie, die sich mit Exantem äußert und sie sind vollständig geimpft und Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Sie ist eine sehr starke Raucherin und sie raucht zwei Schachten Zigaretten pro Tag seit 35 Jahren.
Er trinkt gelegentlich einmal pro Woche ein Glas Wein und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass ihr Vater an Cerebral Tumor vor zehn Jahren gestorben ist und seine Mutter an Herzinsuffizienz leidet.
Sie hat zwei Schwestern und eine Schwestern leidet an Asperger-Syndrom. Sie ist verheiratet, hat zwei Töter und arbeitet als Verkäuferin.
Sie hat Stress wegen der Unterstress.
Die anamnestischen Anwaben deuten am besten auf Akut-Coronare-Syndrom hin.
Die Lungenembolie Myokarditis in Betracht ist eine Differentialdiagnostik.
Sie ist eine sehr starke Schmerzen- und Brengengefühl.
Sie ist eine akute Koronare-Syndrom.
Um meine Verdacht-Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich die Intensivstation des Patienten aufnehmen und natürlich körperlich untersuchen, ein EKG schreiben und mögliche Akut-Coronare-Syndrom zu bestätigen.
Ich werde eine Herz-Solographie oder eine Herz-Echokardiographie durchführen und eine Angeographie, eine Koronare-Angeographie durchführen.
Ich werde den Patienten Schmerzmittel, Morphin verabreichen, Sauerstoff durch Nasenkanüle geben und Nitrat, Aspirin, Betaglucker.
In welcher Situation geben Sie den Patienten Sauerstoff?
Sauerstoff gibt es auf jeden Fall im Herzinfarkt.
Nein, nur 90% Sauerstoff.
Wenn es nötig ist, geben wir Sauerstoff, wenn nötig ist, geben wir Sauerstoff nicht.
Warum geben wir den Patienten keine Sauerstoff?
Weil Oxidativstress erhöht werden kann.
Nein, Oxidativstress verursacht Vasekonstruktion. Vasekonstruktion bedeutet Ischemie.
Herr Oberas, vielen Dank für diese Informationsweise.
Machen Sie weiter.
Ich gebe Morphin, Nitrat, Aspirin, Betaglucker und Heparin.
Ich werde einen PTCH durchführen, um die Veränderung der Gefäße beurteilen und gleichzeitig mit Hilfe eines Ständes behandeln.
Was beachten Sie bei der Eko-Kardiographie?
Bei der Eko-Kardiographie achte ich darauf, ob es eine Herzwandschwache gibt oder Arithmie gibt, Vorhoffileman gibt.
Nein, das ist ein Fehler.
Manche Herzinfarkte können eine Herzrhythmusstörung verursachen, kann ich diese Herzrhythmusstörung auch beurteilen, mit Hilfe Eko-Kardiographie.
Oder eine Geranmischung im Fileman gibt.
Können Sie uns PTCA aufklären?
PTCA ist ein bildgebendes Verfahren.
Mit Hilfe PTCA können wir Coroner und Gefäße beurteilen und gleichzeitig behandeln.
Das ist ein schmerzhaftes Verfahren.
Deswegen müssen wir diese Verfahren unter örtliche Betäubung durchführen.
Durch Phamoral Arter oder Radial Arter können wir Katheter einführen.
Wir müssen mit Hilfe Coroner und Gefäße Katheter einführen.
Mit Hilfe Kontrastmittel machen wir die Gefäße sichtbar.
Wenn es eine Verengung gibt, dilatieren wir zuerst mit Ballon die Gefäße und stellen einen Stand, um eine neue Verengung zu vermeiden.
Das dauert ca. 30 Minuten bis 1 Stunde.
Nach der Behandlung müssen wir die Patienten intensiv beobachten.
Wir müssen die Monitor anziehen und die Patienten engmisch kontrollieren.
Was beachten die Patienten vor der Untersuchung und nach der Untersuchung?
Wenn es ein elektrischer PTCA ist, muss die Patientin nüchtern sein.
Wenn es ein akut myokardial infarkt ist, muss die Patientin keine Vorbereitung machen.
Gibt es eine Alternative Methode für PTCA?
Bei Coroner und Gefäßen kann man die CT-Angeographie nicht invasiv machen.
Aber mit Hilfe der CT-Angeographie kann man keine Vorbereitung machen.
Deswegen muss es ein akut myokardial infarkt sein.
In welcher Situation ist der Coroner-Bypass möglich?
Wenn es eine komplizierte Verengung gibt, muss man eine Bypass-Operation durchführen.
Manchmal wird eine Fulkation verengt.
In welchen Situationen wird diese Situation mit einer Bypass-Operation behandelt?
Eine Möglichkeit ist eine Bypass-Operation.
Was ist die Möglichkeit, eine Bypass-Operation zu machen?
Zuerst muss man sich die Bechdung des Blutes beachten.
Wenn es eine Bechdung ist, würde ich gerne eine CT-Angeographie des Lungen durchführen.
Dann würde ich die Blutanalyse durchführen.
Möchtest du andere Blutanalyse?
Ja, ich möchte natürlich ein D-Dimer durchführen.
Ich möchte ein Troponin-I und T durchführen.
Ich möchte ein CK und CK-MB durchführen.
Ich möchte ein großes Blutbildgerinnungsparameter durchführen.
Wenn wir einen operativen Angriff planen, müssen wir auch Hepatiten,
AntihBSA, HBSA, AntihCB, Antihiv, bestimmen lassen.
Um eine pulmelre Arterie auszusetzen, müssen wir auch eine Arterie-Blutgasanalyse durchführen.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Gasanalyse müssen wir auf jeden Fall bestimmen lassen. Vielen Dank für diese Information.
Guten Tag, Frau Oberastin. Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen die Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Es handelt sich um Frau Edil Traut-Öhm.
Sie ist 51 Jahre alt, 1,56 Meter groß und 71 Kilogramm schwer.
Die Patienten stellen sich heute bei uns wegen seit 45 Minuten bestehender,
starker, drückender, retro-sterniger Schmerzen mit Dispnoe vor.
Die Schmerzen sind in der linken Schulter und in der Unterkiffe aus Strahlen.
Die Schmerzen sind nach einer schlechten Nachricht aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 9 bis 10 von einer Schmerzskala bewertet.
Die Schmerzen werden mit einer Tachikardipaltipation mit einer Neusea einhergeschmissen.
Die Einnahme von Ibuprofen 400 Milligramm hat keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Die Patientin hatte früher ein Problem vor sechs Monaten.
Die Frage nach der Verbeänderung der Brustbeutelung ist verloren.
Die Schuputung wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese hat Folgendes ergeben.
Insomni, Tussis und Obstipation.
Die Patienten an Vorerkrankungen nannt es sich seit zwei Jahren bestehender Konartros.
Seit fünf Jahren bestehende arteriöle Hypertonie.
Seit fünf Jahren bestehende Hyperkolestrinämie.
Der Patient hatte eine Erdzipper vor zwei Jahren.
Er wurde mit Antibiotika behandelt.
Er wurde mit neun Jahren eine Pylonydazynus-Operation durchgeführt.
Er hatte einen Autounfall.
Deswegen war er mit einer Osteosynthes-Operation durchgeführt.
Er nimmt eine Oberarmfraktur.
Er nimmt 400 mg Ibuprofen und eine Voltarenzalbe ein.
Außerdem nimmt er Fluovasthym.
Warum nehmen Sie das?
Der Patient hat Konartros.
Er nimmt die arteriöle Hypertonie und die Hyperkolesterolomie.
Er nimmt 20 mg Fluovasthym ein und 5 mg Norvasthym ein.
Der Patient hat Paraseptemal Allergie, die sich mit Exanthem äußert.
Er ist Raucherin.
Seit 45 Jahren raucht er 22 Schachteln Zigaretten.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol.
Er nutzt Drogen für den Fernseher.
Im Besuch auf die Familie Anamnese
teilt sie mit, dass der Vater mit 70 Jahren an Himtumor gestorben ist.
Die Mutter hat Herzinfizienz.
Sie hat zwei Geschwister.
Eine Schwester hat Aspergillos-Syndrom.
Die Patientin treibt keinen Sport und sie hat viel Stress.
Sie ist verheiratet, lebt mit ihrem Mann.
Sie hat zwei Töchter.
Alle sind gesund.
Sie arbeitet als Verkäuferin.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Akutkorenär-Syndrom aus, da die Patientin dafür typische Symptome aufweist.
Die Patientin leidet unter Rhetro-Sternalschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in der Schulter und in der Kiffe.
Rhetro-Sternalangina. Sie haben recht, Frau Berastin.
Danke schön für diese Informationen.
Außerdem hat sie Todesangst.
Sie sprechen für Akutmyokarte-Syndrome.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen auch Ortisektion und Pulmoner-Emboli in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei der Patientin die BIT-Parameter überwachen.
Dann würde ich die Patientin eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, dass sie zu einer zianosen, zusätzlichen Herzgeräusche vorliegt.
Neben der körperlichen Untersuchung wären Laberunterzüge sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dann würde ich die Blutbild-SRP-BSK-Elektrolyte-Troponin-CK-MB-DiDiMA bestimmen lassen.
Dann würde ich die Blutgasanalyse bestimmen.
Dann würde ich die Patientin eine EKG durchführen.
Außerdem würde ich die Patientin mit einer Röntgen-Torax-Echokardiografie durchführen.
Und möglicherweise werden Herz- und Lungenprobleme ausüben.
Haben Sie während der Anamnese eine Intervention durchgeführt?
Ja, bei der Anamnese würde ich unsere Aufnahmegespräche unterbrechen.
Und was haben Sie gemacht?
Ich habe zuerst die Patienten die Sauerstoffsetzung messen und die Patienten die Vitalparameter überwachen.
Welche Vitalparameter haben Sie?
Ich habe Druck gemessen und Pulse abgetasten.
Dann werde ich den Patienten eine EKG beschreiben.
Dann werde ich den Patienten Morphin verabreichen.
Haben Sie Blutdruck, Pulse, Sauerstoffsetzung, Pulse abgetasten?
Ja.
Und Sie haben eine EKG beschrieben und Morphin veranlassen?
Haben Sie Blut abgenommen?
Ja, ich habe auch Blut abgenommen und mögliche Pulmonerembolie oder Akutmyokrat-Einfarkt auszuschließen.
Dabei werde ich den Patienten Dedema, Troponin und CK-MB durchführen.
Ok.
Dann werden wir die Parameter überwachen.
Dann werden wir die Pulmonerembolie und die Artisektion durchführen.
Die Artisektion wird dann eine coronarengiographiert.
Dann werden wir die Pulsierungen durchführen.
Ok.
Dann werden wir die coronarengiographiert.
Dann werden wir die Pulsierungen durchführen.
Was erwarten Sie im EKG?
Ja, wenn der Patient einen Myokratinfarkt hat, erwarten wir eine Troponinerhochung.
Wenn der Patient einen Myokratinfarkt hat, erwarten wir eine Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt.
Dann werden wir die Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt durchführen.
Wie unterscheiden Sie die Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt und die Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt?
Der Patient hat eine Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt.
Es gibt eine Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt.
Aber wenn der Patient eine Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt hat, ist es eine Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt.
Und die Charakteristik des Schmerzes ist ein Teil der Stabilisierung?
Ja, wenn der Patient eine Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt hat, ist es ein Teil der Stabilisierung des Schmerzes.
Wenn der Patient eine Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt hat, ist es ein Teil der Stabilisierung des Schmerzes.
Es gibt keine Stabilisierung des Schmerzes.
Aber der Patient hat eine Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt.
Eine Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt hat eine Stabil-Nonstabil-Myokratinfarkt.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen anders.
Welche akute Masnahmen würden Sie ergreifen?
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich die Patienten stationärer aufnehmen.
Und ich werde ihnen einen Venouszugang legen und den Patienten mit Problemen,
Statin, Betoblocken und Heparin verabreichen.
Okay. Wann ist eine Bypass-Operation in der Seele?
Wenn es in der Seele, wenn es in der Seele,
im Grunde genommen, in der Seele, in der Seele,
eine Behandlung gibt, werde ich eine Bypass-Planung machen.
Okay. Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten nach der Therapie?
Nach der Therapie empfehlen mir die Patienten Niko-Tinkarenz,
Bewegung, Erhöhung und Stressverminderung.
Der Patient hat viele chronische Erkrankungen.
Es ist wichtig, Blutwerte und Blutdruckwerte und Kolesterinwerte kontrollieren.
Oder regelmäßig auskontrollieren.
Ja, regelmäßig auskontrollieren. Ja, das ist sehr wichtig.
Ich empfehle den Patienten nicht zu essen, sondern auch Obst und Gemüse zu essen.
Ja, okay.
Wir haben keine Zeit, aber ...